well that's good if you're digesting
fast bending Spirit Airlines
it's just [ __ ] that's a really good
point oh you should tell that
jack-in-the-box story there's all right
how do we do this
[Music]
Steven Spielberg this [ __ ] bring him in
start over get the whole thing on a road
trip is like a long ride calm down paint
a picture this is your Jurassic Park
he's not paying attention Breanna and
ask him a question involved I ever been
there
you know Arizona just the state Arizona
no here's no point of reference you're
riffing you're going off script get back
to this story you're never really gonna
work this out when you told Brittany the
story it killed why is it not Kiera you
are dying up here was baby just
pretending to laugh was just not even a
good story make up an ending a disaster
a high-speed chase say yeah I don't know
just tell him what this story's about
jack-in-the-box has better chicken
sandwiches than you'd think I know what
I'm saying you have anywhere nope Yeah
right
god I'm a real good friend
[Music]
you
[Music]